resolvamos el primer problema de la
prueba estándar de california de álgebra
2 la idea es que si ustedes pueden
resolver esto o al menos entender de lo
que tratan esos problemas entonces
tendrán un buen entendimiento de álgebra
2 al menos desde la perspectiva del
estado de california en eeuu
la primera pregunta es cuál es la
solución completa de el valor absoluto
de 3 - 6x igual a 15
pensemos al respecto 3 - 6 no puede dar
15 como nos dicen que el valor absoluto
debe ser 15 entonces 3 menos 6 x menos
6x debe ser igual a 15 o 3 menos 6x
deberá ser igual a menos 15
ya que el valor absoluto de 15 es 15 y
el valor absoluto de menos 15 va a ser
15 también así que cualquiera de estas
dos puede ser verdadera en este caso
vamos a despejar x vamos a restar 3 en
ambos lados me quedan menos 6x igual a
15 menos 3 me va a quedar 12 dividimos
todo entre menos 6 esto entre menos 6
esto entre menos 6 aquí me va a quedar x
igual a 12 entre menos 6 menos 2 este es
un valor eso es una posible respuesta
ahora veamos la otra respuesta vamos a
despejar aquí la equis también igual
vamos a restar 3 en ambos lados de esta
igualdad me va a quedar menos 6x igual a
menos 15 menos 3 va a ser igual a menos
15 16 17 18
muy bien ahora dividimos entre menos 6
ambos lados
- 6 menos 6 va a ser x igual a menos
entre menos va a ser más 18 entre 6 es
igual a 3
así que las respuestas de la solución es
que x puede ser igual a menos 2 x puede
ser igual a 3 que es nuestra opción b
ahora pasemos al siguiente problema
nuestro segundo problema dice
cuáles son los posibles valores de x en
el valor absoluto de 12 menos 4x
igualados es un problema muy similar al
que acabamos de resolver el valor
absoluto de 12 menos x menos 4x lo
escribimos vamos a ponerlo en otro color
12 menos 4 x puede ser igual a 2
12 - 4x puede ser igual a menos 2 ya que
como les comentaba en la ocasión
anterior el valor absoluto de 2 es 2 y
el valor absoluto de menos 2 va a ser 2
cualquiera de estas dos puede ser una
respuesta correcta para esto que nos
piden igual despejamos de este lado
restamos ambos lados menos 12 aquí
quitamos menos 2 se me va a quedar menos
4x
igual a 2 menos 12 va a ser menos 10
dividimos ambos lados entre menos 4
menos 4 me va a quedar x igual a menos
entre menos va a ser más
es cuartos que podemos reducir a este 10
lo puedo dividir entre 2 me voy a quedar
5 el 4 también lo divido entre 2 me va a
quedar 2 me va a quedar igual a 5 medios
o también esto es igual a 2.5
y esta opción del 12 menos 4 x igual a
menos 2
lo mismo restamos menos 12 bueno más
bien sumamos menos 12 en ambos lados
12 - 12 aquí se va a este 12 que es lo
que queremos me va a quedar menos 4x
igual a menos 2 menos 12 menos 14
dividimos esto entre menos 4 porque
quiero dejarla x solita esto entre menos
4x va a ser igual a menos entre menos es
más 14 entre 4 lo puedo simplificar 14
entre 274 entre 2 es 2 va a ser 7 medios
que esto es igual a 3.5 así que x puede
ser 2.5 a 3.5 que es nuestra opción de
veamos el siguiente problema
una boda sofía compro varias docenas de
rosas y varias docenas de claveles las
rosas cuestan 15 dólares la docena los
claveles 8 dólares la docena sofía con
un total de 17 docenas de flores y pago
un total de 192 dólares cuantas rosas
compro
muy bien vamos a definir algunas
variables voy a llamar r a las rosas que
cuestan 15 dólares la docena y voy a
llamarse a los claveles que cuestan 8
dólares por docena
esta es una de una o de 12 r son docenas
de rosas docenas y docenas
rosas
la cee son docenas docenas de claveles
claveles
enunciado nos dicen que la suma de las
docenas de rosas más las docenas de
claveles dan un total de 17 docenas y
también nos dicen que el total gastado
fue de 192 cada docena de rosas costó 15
así que son 15 dólares por docenas de
rosas por esta ere más 8 dólares por
docena de claveles y la suma de estos
dos da un total de 192 dólares así que
aquí tenemos dos ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas y como queremos encontrar la
cantidad de rosas pues vamos a tratar de
cancelar el número de claveles así que a
esta ecuación de aquí arriba la voy a
multiplicar por menos 8 vamos a ponerle
otro color menos 8 por ere menos 8 r
-8% va a ser igual a menos 86 aquí le
cambió el menos 8 c y menos 8 por 17
esto va a ser igual a menos 136 136 y
ahora vamos a sumar estas dos ecuaciones
en estas 2
- 8 r 15 la diferencia es de 77
- 808 se cancela justamente por eso hice
esto menos 136 192 esta va a ser igual a
56 igual a 56
y ahora bueno nos queda que siete
docenas de rosas fue igual a 56 pero nos
preguntan las rosas que se compraron voy
a despejar r para hacerlo voy a dividir
todo entre 7 esto entre 7 esté entre 7
es igual a 87 por 856 entonces se
compraron 8 docenas de rosas que es mi
opción c veamos el siguiente problema
cuál es la solución al sistema de
ecuaciones que se muestra a continuación
con estas tres ecuaciones
estos problemas de tres ocasiones con
tres incógnitas siempre son bastante
densos hay muchas formas de resolver
esto pueden usar matrices matrices
inversas o eliminación de gauss jordan o
el método tradicional de multiplicar las
ecuaciones sumarlas para restringir las
y usaremos esta última para resolverlo
porque no quiero ponerme a explicar
todos los otros métodos aquí lo que
quiero hacer es tomar una de estas
ecuaciones de estas dos ecuaciones para
tratar de cancelar las x en la tercera
ecuación y la mejor forma de hacer esto
es o van a al menos la que a mí más me
gusta es simplificar las ecuaciones y
dejarlas en su mínima expresión por
ejemplo todos los términos en esta
ecuación en esta tercera ecuación son
divisibles entre 3 así que si divido
todo entre 3 me va a quedar menos 6
entre 3 es igual a menos 2 x más 3 entre
3 me queda una más y menos 93 va a ser
menos
z 24 entre 8 es igual para un 24 entre 3
es igual a 8 aquí me queda esta ecuación
simplificada vamos a usar la primera
ecuación con la segunda y la primera con
la tercera para quedarnos con dos
ecuaciones con los variables las 10 y
las setas para cancelar las equis de la
primera simplemente vamos a sumar la con
la tercera vamos a sumar esta ecuación
con esta ecuación que ya simplifica así
que la voy a reescribir aquí abajo con
otro color esta ecuación 2x menos más 3
igual a 8 a 8 escribimos bien el 8 muy
bien sumamos estas ecuaciones menos 2 x
+ 2 x va a ser cero
0 - 3 z 13 está va a ser 0 pero que
creen 8 8 son 16 esto no puede ser 0 no
puede ser igual a 16 esto no tiene
sentido y de hecho aquí no existe una
solución lo que quiere explicarles qué
pasó de manera visual es que cada una de
estas ecuaciones representa un plano de
tres dimensiones y la única manera en la
que no tenemos solución o intersección
entre la primera y la tercera ecuación
es que deben ser ecuaciones paralelas
son planos paralelos y nunca se
intersectan para no entrar en tanto
detalle basta decir que al sumar estas
dos ecuaciones nos resulta un enunciado
sin sentido como que es 0 es igual a 16
por lo que no existe una solución y esa
es la opción c
veamos nuestro último problema de este
vídeo
un administrador del restaurante compro
20 paquetes de panes algunos paquetes
tenían seis panes cada uno y el resto
contenían doce panes cada uno habían 168
panes en total cuántos paquetes de 12
panes comprar a administrador veamos con
mi notación improvisada esto con esta p
subíndice 6 voy a representar los
paquetes con 6 panes
sé que esto sumado con esta otra p
subíndice 12 que son los paquetes con 12
panes me da un total de 20 paquetes como
no me señalan aquí nos dicen que el
total de panes fue de 168 panes así que
cuantos de esos panes vinieron de los
paquetes de 12 piezas bueno se quede por
cada paquete de 6 piezas hay seis panes
por cada paquete de 6 piezas y se que en
cada paquete de 12 piezas pues cuántas
piezas hay 12 12 piezas por paquete de
12 piezas y estas 2 me deben dar como
total 168 panes
tenemos las ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas
quiero conocer cuántos paquetes de 12
panes estos de acá se compran así que
vamos a quitar este de 6 para quitar lo
voy a multiplicar toda esta ecuación por
menos 6 menos 6 de 6
- 6 por p 12 es igual a menos 6
subíndice 12 y 20 por menos 6 es igual a
menos 120 vamos a sumar estas dos
ecuaciones
66 - 66 se van a esto es un cero
12 p 12 - 612 va a ser igual a 66
subíndice 12
y eso es igual a 168 menos 120 es igual
a 48
entonces tenemos que 6
paquetes de 12 piezas es igual a 48 pero
quiero saber cuántos de esos paquetes
hay después despejó esto voy a dividir
entre 6 ambos lados de esta igualdad
esto entre 6 esto entre 6 los paquetes
de 12 piezas son iguales a 48 entre 6 6
por 8 48 son igual a 8 son 8 paquetes de
12 piezas por lo que mi opción es la b
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo